bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono un po dj oggi
andiamo avanti così con strip e rock con
scrive lo sa limiti mi sono confuso
eravamo rimasti nel deserto praticamente
casco pinguino c'era stop in quello che
non so che cosa ci fa nel deserto ma va
beh non mi ricordo neanche come si
chiama st zona ma non fa niente ho
nostalgia di casa
cosa vuol dire igloo non sono a casa
dice così così rischio così vai perfetta
ok adesso lontano da casa giustamente un
igloo nel deserto sotto 50 gradi non so
fatto può durare e devo riuscire ad
arrivare alla st wright ok sono solo
lungo la speedy sono cocco ok vieni più
vicino per attivarmi è più vicini così
cadeau ok i viaggiatori 21 per vedere il
genio esaudire i loro desideri dargli
quel che cercano sono io il genio
ok perfetto e io che ero già convinto di
dovergli chiedere qualsiasi cosa al
genio invece poi sono io ma vige il
genio esaudire a tutti i vostri desideri
allora il grande genio max lo fa tra i
desideri a coloro che lo trovano dai al
mercante tre cose da vendere perfetto e
bin laden è che cazzo ne so dinamite e
bin laden mai vendi questo
no vabbè a parte gli scherzi elimina è
che cazzo ne so cosa devo dargli tre
cose da vendere
incenso ok ora non c'è la birra non è
uno dei tre re magi [ __ ] oro
incenso e mina va bene anche una mina
vai vendi le mine cazzo attento al
cammello attento al cammello che ti
salta in aria
ora incenso e fagioli ovviamen fagiolo
fagiuolo ok cos'è vai di vendita oddio
esplosa la mina
andiamo a saccheggiare oro incenso e
fagioli il deserto non è posto per
vampiri
concedimi tre desideri per renderlo più
sopportabile e cazzo vuol dire che non è
presentabile vampi caso pipistrelli
la prima cosa pipistrello vai adesso
city fabbrico batman è andato bene
pipistrello
che cosa devo fare un capito bene con sé
c'è il deserto non è posto per vampiri
concedimi tra i desideri per rendere più
sopportabile cose al deserto ombrellone
maicon l'ombrellone perfetto è l'ultima
cosa raga sono gli occhiali da sole
dopo questo ma no mettite perfetto ok
e come può chi aveva osato ruolo è
uscito zu bud andato via
voglio essere più divertente concedimi
tre desideri ok
vabbè gli concedo tre desideri per farlo
diventare una lecca lecca che cazzo
dovrebbe essere divertente con lecca
lecca non lo so ma va bene
trombetta ok trombetta non 20 st mai
cosa vuol dire perché perché dovrebbe
essere più felice col trombettista pollo
di gomma divertente di un polo di gomma
non ci trovo nulla perfetta tornatene a
casa sono rimasti bin laden senza al
mezzo di trasporto è il trombettista
caso però va beh noi prendiamoci la st
wright è stata una cosa veramente
stupida totale site 31 perfetto però
vabbè andiamo avanti c'è un coccodrillo
che non mi cavoli striscia c'è un
arcobaleno dio c'è un folletto sono
perplesso questa fine dell'arcobaleno
eppure manca qualcosa
soldi perfetto i soldi alla fine
dell'arcobaleno non è il tesoro
normalmente con la bacinella piena di
soldi ma gli diamo le banconote ed è
contento lo stesso dalla direi di andare
nella zona successiva a sto punto mi ri
miniera sottolineata che cazzo di nome
partiamo benissimo c'è un che cazzo ci
fa un canarino qui proteggimi dal gas
mortale maschera antigas per un canarino
ma cos'è ma perché una maschera antigas
dovrebbe proteggere un canarino vabbè e
andiamo perfetto col carrello mi sento
un figo merda è finita ok continuava di
nuovo che [ __ ]
andiamo anche dopo le rotaie
chissenefrega cacciatori di vampiri
aiutami a capire chi è il vampiro come
faccio ci vuole dell'hiv
stavolta lo devo fabbricare veramente
raglio allora leggiamo il quale dei tre
spunta vampiro diciamo ok perfetto e
trovato prendilo usa usa il carrello di
spider man che può anche sui muri
perfetto allora abbiamo aiutato questo
qui un canarino con la maschera antigas
c'è una sa wright cronica vista salva la
supermodella dal gigantesco ragno le
ragno letale ragno letale io questa
sfida non la faccio perché lo faremo
sfide coi ragni porca trai anche in
scrive l'oms mi fanno schifo i ragni ma
la devo fare
raga io sinceramente so già che mi farà
schifo ok lo sapevo vi giuro che mi fa
sesso anche in scribblenauts se qualcuno
di voi si starà chiedendo ma in skyrim
se c hai giocato come avrei fatto
ho chiuso gli occhi e crea qualcosa per
sconfiggerlo una spada una spada di una
spada gommosa la spada commossa fa il
suo ritorno raga non devo dalla me devo
darle a lei maledizione non riesco più a
prenderla ma che cazzo allora fermi che
finalmente è prendi prendi e vai
perfetto kay non ha funzionato per
niente devo che cazzo ne so io fuoco del
bye bye così perfetto se tieni brutto
stronzo tieni ok
sta andando tutto a fuoco merda ai
adesso è di fuoco brucerò viva allora
direi di fabbricare un iceberg iceberg
come cazzo si ok perfetto mai questo
dovrebbe bastare per se l'è mangiato la
si è mangiato un iceberg che cazzo
cubetto di ghiaccio cioè non gli ha
fatto niente l'iceberg ma un cubetto di
ghiaccio sarà in grado di sconfiggerlo
lo sapevo 2
ok
ecco devo fare adesso adesso diventa di
ghiaccio perfetto è ricomparso l'iceberg
adesso di pietra trovai di pietra io
vado di diamante perfetto raga ce l'ho
fatta con il diamante era più semplice
cazzo no no no no ora devi distruggere
aragno non mi dire che mi viene addosso
ok perfetto cazzo ne so un bazooka è
l'unica cosa mi viene in mente perché
come ragno non è proprio un insetto da
da da spray diciamo è quindi vai
proviamoci vai brutto stronzo se muori
10 falli jack con tre ragni o no allora
che hai fatto distruggere anni i
ragnetti i ragnetti no i ragnetti merda
no ai 8 mi scoprono maledizione come
faccio ok perfetto già presa la st
wright allora che cosa vogliono
se vai distruggi maledizione prendi a st
wright prima che mi massacrino è preso
nella ragnatela completato meno male
speriamo che se ne vadano però finisce
perché se no non so come fa ok perfetto
se ne sono andati vai è in penombra
erano stati un po più traumatici ma
vabbè lasciamo perdere c'è un'altra st
wright tra l'altro qui sotto
trasforma mazzoli non supereroe marzo e
li supera ma perché devo trasformando in
un supereroe cioè fi di mazzon un
supereroe prima dargli qualcosa per
nascondere faccia identità occhiali non
si sa perché anche superman non lo
riconoscono semplicemente mette gli
occhiali e non lo riconosce più nessuno
e fornisce hamas e nulla guardaroba da
supereroe costume da super
no è perfetto mai lo zio che figo c'è
anche la scritta ma la gli occhiali mi
servivano max l'ape bisogno di un
superpotere api che l'aggettivo per dare
massima un'abilità speciale
invincibilità
ok invincibile vai perfetto ok va beh
non è un aggettivo poi così eclatante ma
la prima cosa che mi è venuto in mente
era comunque ce l'abbiamo fatta
marchionne incassa maglia è bellissimo è
un gran figo devo dire allora abbiamo
abbiamo aiutato tutti qui se quanto
abbiamo preso già 3 st wright nagar
cos'è questo aiuta ci siamo intrappolati
mi ricorda vagamente qualcuno raga sto
cavernicolo però va beh non lo so forse
un antenato di jack sparso
e vabbè allora aiutiamoli come faccio mi
serve tipo un po di fuoco cova e fuoco
ok per no così mi do forni da fuoco da
solo ecco perfetto come non detto
perfetto vai ok ci siamo sono liberi era
glaciale manca sid
vabbè totale st wright 30 qua madonna
ho preso 4 st wright di già hai bisogno
di qualcosa da di qualcosa per cacciare
l'imponente mammut e allora direi clava
gommosa che cazzata che gr
ma no ma perché perché se noi ci
telefona bastardo unemia visse che di
mammut per tutti i ragazzi vuole
usufruire offro io comunque benvenuto a
grotta dei di qualcosa ma ho fatto in
tempo a leggere chi è quello con
sacchetto ok oddio c'è una gorgone c'è
una gorgone malizia sono tutti di pietra
c'è anche un fratello di maxwell dai
alla triste medusa un partner romantico
affinché ci lasci tranquilli
raga il compagno giusto di medusa ce
l'ho io credetemi è quello giusto
ok
renderman ok eccolo è un po piccolo
facciamo un po più grande anno perfetto
e si è ingrandito vai da è uno slider
mai giocato ma no io la farei incazzare
se o che bello sono innamorati ragazzi
lo sapevo che sarebbe stato amore a
prima vista oa primo braccio però va beh
non importa noi andiamo avanti
non lo so perché ma ho la netta
sensazione che per una volta sia lowes
lander man ad essere stuprata ma noi
proseguiamo andiamo avanti
no fermo brutto stronzo voglio un
passaggio
ieri vi ho lanciato la bistecca hai
bisogno di qualcosa si è bene io ti do
un cazzo perché non mi viene anche un
passaggio pescato tutto il giorno ma non
c'è niente da prendere se prendessi me a
bordo sarebbe un'idea ma non fa niente
salmone facciamo che sono buono oggi dai
no 1 non fabbrica oddio ma che cazzo e
salmone più pesante del mondo
madonna ma come cazzo è che si piega lab
la barca quando peschi e vabbè facciamo
finta di niente
buongiorno a lei sono troppo spaventoso
per essere amato ma no dai poverino
tollit lo vedi che che sei bellissima ok
facciamo una bella cosa eri mettitelo va
beh
mi dispiace troppo ma no dai su via devi
essere un figo puoi diventare chiunque
può diventare un figo stai tranquillo
allora facciamo così e amato
semplicemente la già bottino ma perché
vabbè è diventato un playboy ma pazienza
non importa o c'era da dire di andare di
sopra perché c'è cappuccetto rosso cosa
vuoi
ho bisogno di provviste da portare alla
nonna
facciamo che cazzo ne so panino alla
vabbè al prosciutto cos'è panino
asciutto
va bene lo stesso vai è uno spuntino per
la notte cose vai nel pozzo no dov'è la
nonna che cazzo stai andando a eccola
sembra la mia prof di matematica
vabbè andiamo chi è questo aiuta il
pioniere sulla pista degli oregon
ok in viaggio verso una cosa per l'asso
wright non ho mica capito è ok va bene
allora cosa devo fare questo pellegrino
va verso ovest ma qual è la sua
professione fornisce un oggetto per fa
di lui un agricoltore un falegname e un
impiegato di banca
facciamo la legna a sto punto facciamo
la legna così diventa falegname ok
perfetto dio perché se si è messo ok
perfetto e morto il 2 avrei un animale
per sostituirlo va bene
t rex michael t rex perfetto vai
sostituito questo treno che una bellezza
el ho provato io negli episodi
precedenti credimi sto finendo il cibo
non so come cacciare che a qualcuno che
possa insegnarmelo bear grylls in
effetti sarebbe l'unico che può
insegnarti a trovare cibo in queste
situazioni comunque è che cacciatore
cacciator cacciatore perfetto
mio dio che mira of cazzo aperti a tutti
gli animali che si ammazzano esplodono
con le piste che cioè sono arrivate alla
fine del cammino ora che la
un'abitazione in cui possa vivere
facciamoci un mega villone se lo sapevo
ti facevo anche la piscina ma non ci sta
perfetto st wright si abbandona raga 5
star in un episodio l'ho mai fatta 5 st
wright me ne rimane uno e dovrei
riuscire a sbloccare la parte successiva
vabbè raga direi di fare l'ultima sfida
poi la finisco qui voglio esprimere un
desiderio ok
guarda il servizio genio l'ho finito
prima dovevi prendere il ticket comunque
va bene lo stesso proviamo a fare
qualcosa
bacchetta magica ok bacchetta magica
incantesimo perfetto dimmi cosa vuoi
mi sento un fanta genitore vabbè tieni
prendi lacoste punto fai da sola è un
self service hanno capito la moneta ci
voleva la moneta per il pozzo raga non
certo non c'ero arrivato scusatemi per
che cazzo cioè ma che desiderio è ma
perché uno dovrebbe desiderare di
cavalcare un unicorno arcobaleno ho
chiesto io vabbè lasciamo perdere
sono un mago che cazzo vuol dire vabbè
direi di finire l'ultima sfida così
prendo la sesta st wright aiuto aiutarli
con oggettiva la mia casa per impedirgli
di mangiarla stanno mangiando la tua
casa per che cosa sono hansel e gretel
vabbè che cazzo un aggettivo che la
rende immangiabile
e che ne so amara la casa mara perfetto
a manca la nonna ma loro mica vista la
mia casa un po triste ci vuole un tocco
di colore extreme makeover fa vj edition
colorata perfetto mai è bella anche i
fiori le coccinelle tutto un tocco di
colore perfetto livello completa livello
completato ha sì ho completato tutto il
livello raga completamente
non lo ha preso l'ultima st wright mi
manca praticamente niente 5 st wright in
un episodio sono un record comunque non
so se riuscirò di nuovo a fare una cosa
del genere ragazzi stiamo avvicinando al
finale manca pochissimo
vabbè comunque per questo episodio direi
di concludere qui c'è medusa che ha
ucciso lo slider man
ok è una cosa molto macabra ma non fa
niente
va bene no io direi di finire qui
l'episodio raga
come al solito servi dove è piaciuto
lasciate un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come in ogni video
trovate nella descrizione se non siete
ancora iscritti iscrivetevi noi ci
vediamo al prossimo video bella ragazzi